اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره المفصله من
العربيه والبدايه بالعالم
احتجاجات مستمره في ايران ردا للاعتقالات
العشوائيه وفضه تظاهرات بالقوه
تونس تدخلوا مرحله الصوت الانتخابيه عشيه
الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات البرلمانيه
وخدوم حاضر يسود مستوطنه النبي يعقوب بعد
ساعات من هجوم قتل فيه سبعه اسرائيليين
البدايه من شرق اوكرانيا حيث قال مستشار
القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه
بالقرب من مدينه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه
وانطلقت سفرات ونذار من الغارات الجويه
ليلا في عده مناطق في اوكرانيا وفقا
لبيانات الغارات الجويه الصادره عن وزاره
التحول الرقمي في البلاد وظهرت خريطه
الوزاره على الانترنت ان التحضيرات من
الغارات الجويه كانت ساريه المفعول في
منطقتي بولطا وديني برو الاوكرانيتين
بالاضافه الى الاجزاء التي تسيطر عليها
اوكرانيا
موديلات موديلات العربيه رائد الاخبار
اهلا بك يا رائد اذا في اكثر من مواجهه
ترافق القوات الروسيه التي تتقدم في بعض
المناطق الاوكرانيه ما اخر تطورات واين
تدور ابرز الاشتباكات
نهاركم طيب محمد بالفعل ما زالت المعارك
مستعره على محاور عده خاصه في الشرق
الاوكراني في مقاطعه ادانيه منها مار كواف
ديفكو
بالفعل يعني تنشر القوات الروسيه الياتها
وجنودها على كل تلك المحاور من اجل بسط
النفوذ على جميع المدن التي يسيطر عليها
حتى الان الجيش الاوكراني في مقاطعه
ادينيس لابد ان هناك خطه روسيه لاكمال
السيطره على كامل المقاطعه لنبدا من
اجلدار حيث المعارك المحتدمه الاله
العسكريه الروسيه الثقيله تقصف بعنف قواعد
الجيش الاوكراني المتمركز داخل المدينه
تقول السلطات هنا بانها دمرت خمس منصات
للمدافع مدافع هاوزر الامريكيه وانا الجيش
الاوكراني ما زال يخزن الذخيره في همم
مناطق مختلفه من المدينه تحاول القوات
الروسيه اقتحام مدينه اوغلادار من الناحيه
الجنوبيه واظهرت فيديوهات لحجم ال- اا قصف
الكبير او كثافه التي الذي تنفذه القوات
الروسيه في ذلك المحور ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تطوق المدينه من عده نواحي
الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الشرقيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من
اجل الاندفاع اكثر ودفع الجيش الاوكراني
الى الانسحاب حتى الان ليس هناك اي حديث
عن سيطر على اي جانب سوى ان هناك قتال
شوارع في المناطق الجنوبيه وعمليات تنظيف
من يعني في ذلك المحور كما وصفتها سلطات
المحليه هناك
باخمه
قبل الحديث كيف تستطيع القوات الروسيه
الاخيره خاصه فيما يتعلق بدبابات النوعيه
التي يتوقع بان تغير
جرارات المعركه
اولا يعني تصريحات موسكو تشير الى ان
الغرب اصبح
منغمسا ومنخرطا في العمليات العسكريه وفي
الصراع روسيا الاوكراني
ويربما يصبح قريبا يعني عدوا لروسيا كما
هي اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب لانه يعني كان
يعتبر الاتحاد الروسي الغرب هو عدو او
مشارك غير مباشره اليوم يقولون اذا وصلت
هذه الاسلحه سنعتبر ان الغرب او امريكا
وبريطانيا اعداء مباشر في هذه المعركه
وصفت ال- يعني ال- ال- القوات العسكريه
الروسيه والدفاع الروسيه وصفت الوضع يعني
فورا وصول الاليات بانه سيتم الطحن هذه
الاليات وستكون هدفا مشروعا للقوات
الروسيه ايضا يقولون بان الاعداد الفرديه
التي طرحت من هذه الدبابات
نيو بارد وافرام الامريكيه
واليابارد الالمانيه هي اعداد فرديه ولن
تؤثر كثيرا على مسار المعركه لكن بكل
الاحوال ستكون مستهدفه قبل وصولها الى ارض
المعركه كما ان الحديث عن ان وصولها سيكون
في شهر اغسطس القادمه ان امامنا عده اشهر
وربما تقوم روسيا بالتقدم والاستيلاء اكثر
على اراضي وسيطر عليها وبصمه فوقها حتى
تبعد القوات الاوكرانيه عن خطوط التماس
القريبه من المدن او المدنيين تحديدا
الغربيه كنت تتحدث ذلك عن محمود
اخمد هي ايضا محور هام جدا حيث ان القوات
الخاصه الروسيه قوات فاجنر ماذا لتطوق
المدينه من ثلاث نواحي الجنوبيه والشرقيه
والشماليه الشماليه بعد ان سيطرت على
مدينه سوليدار وتتقدم ايضا من منطقه
سوليدار من الناحيه الشماليه والجنوبيه
نحو سيرفس كمالا ونحو باخم جنوبا وبالفعل
تسيطر على بلدات ربما يكون التقدم بطيء
لكنها بالفعل تتقدم المحور الاهم في هذه
المدينه وباختصار محمد هو جنوب المدينه
هنا قتال شوارع تقوم قوات بادنوربيه
الوصول الى بلده همم ايفانا فك وايضا
كوردوكا بعد ان سيطرت على كل شيفكه
والحديث عن قتال شوارع في اطراف المدينه
الجنوبيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
توجهنا الى المناطق الشماليه الغربيه من
مقاطعه دانيتك المناطق الساخنه جدا نحن
الان على اطراف مدينه مارينكا وهنا في هذا
الاتجاه تدور معارك طاحنه ما بين الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني وتعتبر هذه المدينه
قريبه جدا من مدينه باخمط التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الاوكراني ويطوقها الجيش
الروسي من جوانب ثلاثه الناحيه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه والشماليه بعد السيطره على
سوليدار
دخلت قوات وفاكنر من جنوب مدينه وبعد وصول
المقاتلين الى العمق الاوكراني من اطراف
بلده ايفانكا جنوب المدينه تشهد المنطقه
قتال شوارع بين الطرفين في ذات الوقت الذي
اعلنت فيه كيف انسحاب جيشها رسميا من
مدينه سوليدار المعارك الاعنف على الطابق
الثاني من هذا الموقع هذا هو مصنع قديم
للحليب هذا هو حال المصنع اصبح ثكن عسكري
كبيره للقوات الروسيه امام محوره مدينه
اوغلودار جنوب المقاطعه فيطوق الجيش
الروسي المدينه بنفس استراتيجيه التطويق
مدينه
ويستمر بقصف مراكز الجيش الاوكراني داخل
المدينه مع محاوله اقتحامها من الناحيه
الجنوبيه بعد ان سيطر على طريق السريع
الذي يوصل الامدادات من مدينه بكروكا شمال
غربي
اثبت الفرقه الخاصه في الجيش الروسي لنغطي
عمليه اقتحام اواخر مدينه مارينكا اما
محور رومارينجا فما زال يشهدوا معارك
واشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه اضافه الى
القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين مع سيطره
القوات الروسيه على مواقع جديده في الثلث
الاخير من المدينه على الخط الاول من
المواجهه مع الجيش الاوكراني في ذاك الطرف
نرى البنايات المدمره من المدفعيه
والدبابات والقصف وحتى
الاشتباكات بالرشاشات هذه هي المعارك وهذه
هي مدينه ماريكا في مقاطعه دانيت لقناتي
العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
ماركه دانيت
وفي ظل هذه التطورات تخطط بوسكو الى تعزيز
نظام الدفاع الجوي في منطقه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه باوكرانيا بمنظومه
وستكون هذه الانظمه قادره على اسقاط
الطائرات بدون الطيار والصواريخ مما في
ذلك الصواريخ من طراز هاي مارس
فرنسا
في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه
ليس هناك
مانع ليس هناك محظور لكن في معايير طبعا
ثلاثه نقاط مهمه الاولى اننا
نريد ان يكون الدعم او تكون
المسانده فعاله سريعه
الله تساهم في التصعيد وثا لا تضعف قدرت
فرنسا
ومع دعم او تصاعد الدعم الغربي كيف بدات
الحرب شكله وتحولا في ميزان القوى
الاوروبيه نحو الشرق بعيدا عن موسكو في
تحولات قد ترسم ملامح نظام العالمي جديد
حراره نيران تلك المدافع في اوكرانيا لم
تغير ملامح هذه الارض فقط لكنها غيرت ايضا
وضعيه الدول في اوروبا فبدلا من فرنسا
والمانيا والتاثير السياسي والاقتصادي
والعسكري القوي لكل منهما سطعت بولندا
ودول البلطيه
من اندلاع الحرب شكل الدعم لاوكران يا
معضله اساسيه بولندا والدول البلطيق مثل
القوه الدافعه الاساسيه وراء الدعم مقابل
حاله تشبه الشلل انتب الزعماء اوروبا
التقليديين فرنسا والمانيا
بعد شهور من الجدل لارسال الدبابات
الغربيه الاوكرانيا حسبت الضغوط المبذوله
من شرق ووسط اوروبا قرارات الدعم العسكري
لكيف حيث شكلت بولندا احدى جماعه الضغط
الرئيسيه لمحاوله اقناع المانيا المتردده
بارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا والتفويض
الدولي الاخرى للقيام بذلك
وسط ملامح التغيير التي تفرض نفسها يوصل
الرئيس الفرنسي اماله في ان يكون جزءا من
اي مفاوضات سلام المستقبليه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وذهب الى حد الحديث عن اعطاء
ضمانات امنيه لروسيا الامر الذي اثار غضب
الكثيرين في اوروبا وليس فقط في الشره
المانيا لم تكن حكومتها مستعده للحرب
ناهيك عن القطع المفاجئ للطاقه والتجاره
الروسيه ومع تزايد القلق بشان اعتماد ممثل
على الصين تواجه المانيا الحاجه الى اعاده
تشكيل اقتصادها القائم على التصدير
والمبني على الغاز الروسي الرخيص والتجاره
غير المقيده مع الصين
الحرب في اوكرانيا احدث التغييرات كبيره
في ميزان القوه التقليديه تغييرات وعلى ما
يبدو لن تقف عند هذا الحد عصام عبد السلام
العربيه
وفي ايران طرح مجموعه من الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
مشروع قرار يدعو الى تعزيز العقوبات الى
ملكيه ضد النظام الايراني
هذا وظهرت مقاطع فيديو تجدد التضاهرات
الليليه في عدد من المدن الايرانيه حيث
خطف المحتجون في حي طهران فارس في العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران
العنف والاعتقالات العشوائيه لمتظاهرين
وفضل احتجاجات بالقوه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هو في مدينه صفاقس بمحافظه كردستان
الايرانيه اظهرت مقاطع فيديو الدراما
النار في منزل احد المخبرين الذين يعملون
لصالح الامن الايراني
[موسيقى]
كشفت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه عن
وصول عدد المحتجين الذين يواجهون خطر
الاعدام الى اكثر من 100 متظاهر المنظمه
التي تتخذ من اوسلو مقر لها كشفه النيران
اعدمت ما لا يقل عن 55 شخصا في يناير
الجاري وحده
الناس
كشفت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ايضا
عن مقتل نحو 500
هذا هو طالبه منظمه العفو الدوليه ايران
بالغاء احكام الاعدام الصادره ضد ثلاثه
محتاجين قالت انهم تعرضوا لتعذيب وحشين
انه على سلطات الايرانيه الغاء احكام
الادانه واحكام الاعدام الصادره بحق
الشبان
المتعلقه بمشارتهم السلميه
في الخارجيه الفرنسيه في تصريحاته للعربيه
من قبل النظام الايراني ضد المتظاهرين
وعمليه الاعدام التي تنفيذها سلطات النظام
ضد عدد من المحتاج
القمع العنيف
ضد المتظاهرين الايرانيين المدنيين
السلميين
هذا القمر اذانه تم ااه
ونحن ايضا ندين اللجوء الى عقوبه الاعدام
باتريس جدد ايضا موقف فرنسا ثابت من
الرعايه الفرنسيين المعتقلين في ايران
واكد ان بلاده ترفض اتهام طهران لهم
بالتجسس وصفه نيالهم برهائم دوله ايران
للافراج عنهم وبشكل فوري وجود سبعه
فرنسيين محتجزين
من السلطه الايرانيه
ايران بالافراج عنهم كلهم اضافه لذلك يوجد
ايضا محتجزين من دول اخرى او نحن بتنسيق
في في هذه الدول نحن ايضا قلق جدا بالنسبه
الى سحر واحد من الرعايه نعتبرهم دوله
ليسوا همم جواسيس
فنرفود هذا همم هذه العباره وهذا ال-
التعريف
اوضحت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه صار خادم
والتي انتقلت الى اسبانيا بعد مشاركتها في
بطوله دوليه من دون حجاب انها رفضت امرا
من السلطات في ايران طلبه بتصوير فيديو
تعتذر فيه عن المشاركه في البطوله دون
حجام وضحتنا انها تلقت عريبات كذلك بالقاء
اللون على الغرب على قرارها بعدم تغطيه
الراس
لم يمنعها من ممارستها حتى لو على طاوله
مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسباني في لقطات بدات
فيها اكثر ارتياحا ظهرت لاعبه الشطرنج
الايرانيه ساره خادم في ضيافه رئيس
الوزراء الاسباني وهي التي اختارت المنفى
وحريتها على البقاء تحت قمع النظام في
ايران الذي لم يتاخر في الاعلان عن انكاره
لها
امراه الملك
في لقاء اخير مع صحيفه تلغراف البريطانيه
ذكرت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه انها رفضت
امرا من السلطات في ايران طالبتها بتصوير
فيديو تعتذر فيه عن المشاركه في بطوله
العالم لشطرنج في كازاخستان دون حجاب
موضحا انها تلقت كذلك تعليمات بالقاء
اللوم على ضغوط الغرب على قرارها بعدم
تغطيه راسها
مع الحجاب لست انا ولا اشعر انني بحاله
جيده ولذا اردت ان انهي هذا الوضع ولذا
قررت عدم ارتدائه بعد الان لعبه الشطرنج
حرب بين معسكريين تتساوى قوهما هدف كل
المعسكر هو اسر ملك المعسكر الاخر بوضعه
في مركز لا يستطيع معه الهرب والهروب من
بلدها الام ومن قمع النظام الايراني
واستبداده خاصه مع النساء الايرانيات هو
مختاره الايرانيه لاعبه الشطرنج صارت خادم
في خطوه فسرها كثيرون بانها جاءت دعما
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي تشهدها ايران منذ
عده اشهر
[تصفيق]
املوا ان اكون الشخص الوحيد المسؤول عما
فعلته نشعر بترحيب كبير في اسبانيا لكننا
تركنا بعضا من اهم الاشياء في الحياه في
ايران لذلك هناك مشاعر مختلطه
صار خادم تعد خامسه رياضيه محترفه في لعبه
الشطرنج تغادر ايران خلال السنوات الاخيره
ومعظمهن قررنا ذلك بعد فتره وجيزه من
مشاركتهن في منافسات دوليه من دون ارتداء
الحجاب
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
وتمت قرغيزستان ترسيم الحدود بينهما لتضع
بدالك نهايه العقود من نزاع الحدود
الاتفاق الذي يوافق عليه البرلمان العام
الماضي بعد ثلاثه عقود من المحادثات خلال
زياره الرئيس الاوزبكي
القرنبيسيه باشا
القران الكريم
بين سكان المحليين حول الوصول الى المياه
والاراضي الزراعيه
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
نشوب حرب مع الصين في 20 25
[موسيقى]
طيب
الديمقراطيه الرقميه الجمعه الواحده بعد
منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
من كل مكان
تتوالى مع كل لحظه
ويؤثرون فيها
[موسيقى]
سنخبركم بما يحدث من حولنا
مجريات تهمكم
وقائع ترسم الصوره
كما حدثت واين ما حدثت
ستعرفون اسبابها
تفاصيلها
وتداعيتها هذا المساء
على شاشه العربيه
غابه كل مظاهر الحمله الدعايه في الفضاءات
العامه والاماكن المخصصه لتعليق برامج
المترشحين للانتخابات التشريعيه في دورها
الثاني او تكاد هيئه الانتخابات تقول انها
وفرت كل الظروف لوجستيه والبشريه لانجاح
الاستحقاق الانتخابيه اما منظمات المجتمع
المدنيه فتعيب على المسار بعد التسرع في
الاجراءات والاجال واداره العمليه المشرفه
الانتخابات
للانتخابات
هم اكثر من 700 منهم 455
45 سنه سامحوني ملاحقه
ومع اقتراب يوم الاقتراع بقي الشارع
منشغلا بظروف البلاد الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه واختلفت الاراء فيه حول اهميه
الانتخابات التشريعيه في وقت يؤكد
المتابعون اهميه تركيز البرلمان الجديد في
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه
الوجوج الجديده
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
بعد مقتل اسرائيليين في مستوطنه النبي
يعقوب
وكان سبعه اشخاص قد قتلوا في اطلاق نار
في مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه
نحن في حي بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله
على مرمى حجر من مكان العمليه التي جرت في
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب هنا المنفذ دخل من
هذه المنطقه تماما تجاه المستوطنه وصل الى
المنطقه
القريبه وفتح النار عمليا بعد ان ترجع من
السياره على مستوطنين قتل على الاقل
ثمانيه واصاب اخرين ومن ثم حاول العوده
الى حي بيت حنينا الى المنطقه العربيه
يمكن ان نرى السياره مازال مركونه بعد ان
اشتبك هناك مع قوات من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
التي صارعت الى اغلاق المكان الذي تحول
الى محج للسياسيين بنيامين نتنياه وصله
وكذا ايضا وزير الامن همم القومي
الاسرائيلي المتطرف هناك اجراءات امنيه
اسرائيليه صارمه همم اتخذت في القدس
الشرقيه المح وكذا ايضا في الضفه الغربيه
خشيه من ان تستمر العمليات الفرديه التي
تمت في هذه المنطقه ان تكون هناك موجه
علما ان لا قبل تقريبا لاسرائيل لوقف هذه
العمليات لانها لا تملك معلومات
استخباراتيه بشانها عاده زياد حلبي
العربيه بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله
اسرائيليه
في الضفه الغربيه
حول التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه انه
لم ينتج عن الجلسه اي شيء ملموس بسبب
مواقف بعض الدول في اشاره الى الولايات
المتحده
لدينا ازمه حقيقيه فعلى مجلس الامن ان
يتحرك ولكن يمكنكم ان تتخيلوا لماذا لا
يمكن لمجلس الامان ان يتخذ خطوات كانت
هناك مناشدات من الفلسطينيين ومن دول
اعضاء تطلب من اسرائيل عدم القيام بالمزيد
من الاعمال للاستفزازيه ولكن ما زال مجلس
الامن غير قادر على توجيه اي رساله قويه
ولست متفائلا بخصوص اتخاذ المجلس اي من
الخطوات الاضافيه الوضع يمكن ان ينفجر في
اي وقت مع عواقب اضافيه وعلينا ان نفكر
كمجلس امن بشكل جدي حول خطواتنا القادمه
معنى من القدس مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاصيه اهلا بك لانا هل تم تسجيل اي
تطورات او تصعيد بعد هجوم امس
[موسيقى]
حدث فعليا ما تخشاه او الجهاز الامني على
الاسرائيلي حدث ما يخشاه فعليا وهو رد على
هجوم او رد على العمليه في جنين بعمليات
فرديه دعنا ان نشير اليها كانها عمليات
فعليه فرديه فراينا بالامس فعليا هذه
العمليه التي وصفها مفتش الشرطه العام في
اسرائيل بانها يعني احدى اخطر واصعب
العمليات مقارنه ايضا بالسنوات الماضيه
فمثل هذه العمليات الفرديه من الصعب جدا
ومن المستحيل دعنا نقول ان تكتشف عنها من
طريقه مبكره الشرطه الاسرائيليه ومحاوله
تمنعها لذلك فعليا نحن نشهد حاليا توتر
كبير في القدس هناك انتشار ايضا واسع همم
وفي همم من قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
مناطق مختلفه في القدس الشرقيه اضافه الى
يعني تع القوات في الضفه الغربيه تحسبا
لاي عمليه جديده انتقاميه حسب ما تعتبرها
اسرائيل طيب هناك نقطه مهمه جدا ايضا فيما
يتعلق بعمليات الاعتقال والمداهمات التي
تقوم بها السلطات الاسرائيليه في الضفه
الغربيه هل توقفت تلك العمليات بعد همم
حادثه النبي
يعقوب كان هناك ايضا انتقام من قبل
المستوطنين المسلحين في الضفه الغربيه فقد
ايضا اصابه خمس فلسطينيين في نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله فاذا توقف يعني
القوات الاسرائيليه لن يتوقف المستوطنين
المسلحين وهم ايضا يملكون هذا السلاح
المرخص من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه ودعنا ايضا ننوه بان اليوم سوف
يكون في هناك اجتماع يعني لتقييم الاوضاع
الامنيه ويعني سوف يجتمع الوزراء
الاسرائيليين في هذا الاجتماع
يقرر ما الخطوه التاليه التي سيقوم بفعلها
ولكن ايضا يعني نحن ضروري
الحاليين في هذه الحكومه الجديده لا
يملكون الخبره همم الكبيره وانما يعني
لديهم ايديولوجيات متشدده ومتطرفه فعليا
سوف ننتظر حتى يعني يتم الاعلان ما الق
الجديده بالنسبه للحكومه
حقيقي لهذه الحكومه التي اشارته اليها
ويقال عنها بي ان يمنيه متطرفه ولكن يبقس
هو المهم الى اين وصلت جهود التهدئه وهل
ضغط اصوات التصعيد على تلك الجهود حتى
الان
في الضفه الغربيه وايضا في القدس ولكن بعد
ايام من لقاء يعني من من اللقاء
الاسرائيلي مع اللقاء الاردني يعني لم
يحدث شيء وانما زاد التصعيد
وشاهدنا ايضا العمليه في جنين ففعليا ايضا
كان هناك طلبات من قبل السلطه الفلسطينيه
بالتهدئه ومطالبه اسرائيل به وقف العمليات
الاستفزازيه ضد الفلسطينيين خاصه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله ولكن اسرائيل استمرت في
هذه العمليات وكانت اكبرها واصعبها
بالنسبه لي الفلسطينيه همم عمليه جنين
التي ايضا ذكرتهم باجتياح جنين عام 2002
التي يعني نشب عنها مجزره فعليه وايضا
شبهها الفلسطينيين هذه العمليه بالمشجره
الثانيه
ما يحدث هنا هو استمرار في الاستفزاز
الاسرائيلي واستمرار العمليات وايضا
العمليات الاغتياليه الدائمه في الضفه
الغربيه فربما التهدئه سوف تكون شبه
مستحيله حاليا بعد انفجار الاوضاع في اا
في الشارع الفلسطيني هنا فشهدنا ايضا يعني
هناك همم في همم في مواقع التماس كان هناك
اشتباكات ايضا ما بين الفلسطينيين والشباب
الفلسطينيين مع القوات الاسرائيليه على
مناطق مختلفه وحواجز مختلفه همم في الضفه
الغربيه وايضا في القدس الشرقيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
في تصريح اللفت رجعها جنرالنا امريكيه
تدخل حربا مع الصين عامه
على الاستعداد للقتال اعتبارا من هذا
العام
الجنرال الامريكي مايكل
الى سلاح
الجونيه لعام 20 24 ستمنح الزعيم الصيني
للوصول الى البيت الابيض
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
السلطات النيوزلنديه تعلن ان رحلات
الدوليه من مطار اوكلاند الدولي
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت تسلطات نيوزلانديه
نيوزلندا
المسافرين
بسبب سوء الاحوال الجويه
في لبنان ورغم اللازمه الاقتصاديه التي
يعاني منها اقبل بعض المواطنين على
الاستثمار في مصادر الطاقه البديله وخاصه
الالواح الشمسيه
لكنها غيابه تنظيم والمراقبه ادى الى فوضى
في هذا القطاع
هكذا تبدو بيروت من الاعلى
عاصمه لبنان التي لقبت بمدينه البطون
امتلات اسطح امنيتها بالواح الطاقه
الشمسيه
جهود فرديه مبعثره اعتقد اللبنانيون انها
ستخرجهم من ازمه انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
ولكن مع غياب الرقابه ودخول الدخلاء بدلا
من المهندسين الى ورش تركيب الواح الطاقه
ادى الى احتراقها وتطيرها احيانا لبنان
طرف حوالي 900 مليون دولار لو صرفناهم
بطريقه منظمه كانت الحلول هتكون افضل افضل
منظمه بدنا مشوهه للبيئه خطر على السلامه
العامه
كانت بتكون مفيده اكثر من ناحيه انتاج
الكهرباء والكل يقدر يستفيد
شركه ابي حيدر في صياغه قانون الطاقه
المتجدده الموزعه لتنظيم القطع لكنه وزاره
الطاقه لم تاخذ به رغم مرور ثلاثه اعوام
هي نفس الوزاره التي بنت على مقربه منها
اول حقل شمسي نموذجيه في لبنان وهو مشروع
الطاقه الشمسيه الوحيد الذي تعاهدت به
الدوله ليتبين ان كل هذه الالواح لا تعمل
بسبب ربطها بخط تغذيه خال من الطاقه في ظل
التقنين الحاد مثال عن سوء الاداره التي
حدثنا عنها غسان بيضون مديره عامل استثمار
السابق في وزاره الطاقه
لحتى تاخذ الالتزام بالاستثمار همم
همم بالقطاع على عشرات سنين همم وزير مش
عم يدير مصالح الدوله عامله مندير مصالحه
ومصالح المستثمرين اللي بيدعموه
بناء الحقول في مناطق نائيه واستجرار
الطاقه للمدن والقرى لكن اعتماد المواطنين
على انفسهم لتامين الواح الطاقه ادى الى
صرف الكثير من الاموال مقابل القليل من
الاستفاده كان بامكان الطاقه البديله ان
تتحول الى جزء من حل مستدام لمشكله
الكهرباء في لبنان لكن الفساد والفضه كان
كافيلين كالعاده بتحويل النعمه الى نقمه
اغنيه يتيم العربيه بيروت
اعلنت الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس دونالد
ترامب الرئيس الجمهوريه السابق امام
الجمهور اليوم في ايطاليا لانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 20 24
[موسيقى]
او نقله النوعيه في حياته السياسيه بعد ان
خرج ترامب من الانتخابات النصفيه نوفمبر
الماضي بجراح لم تندمل بخساره عدد من
المرشحين الجمهوريين الذين دعمهم يطلق
حملته الرئاسيه للعام 24 بمخوف من تكرار
ذات السيناريو المخيبي لامال المصري ترامب
معركه ترامب السياسيه تبدا من ولايه مهاجر
حيث يختبر الرئيس الامريكي السابق قوته
كمرشحين في خطاب امام مئات القاده
الجمهوريين
ليتوجهها بعدها لولايه سوف كارولينا وهي
التي ساعدت في تمهيد طريقه ليصبح مرشح
الحزب الجمهوريه في عام 2016
لكنها خذلته عام 2020 حين ترشح للرئاسه
احد اهم اعمده ذلك تاييد هو السنه
الجمهوري الانستغرام
جمهوري المنتخب حديثا راس الفراي لكن في
الوقت نفسه ستغيب اسماء العديد من
الجمهوريين البارزين احدهم هو المدعي
العام للولايه الين ويلسن وهو مع اسماء
جمهوريه اخرى ترغب في البقاء على الحياد
بعيدا عن الدراما السياسيه والجدل الذي
يلاحق ترامب شبكه سين انا الامريكيه ترى
بان الاحداث المتسارعه على الساحه
السياسيه وظهوره وثائقي سريه حكوميه في
منزل بايدا وكذلك في منزل النائب السابق
لترامب مايك برنس قد توفراني فرصه جديده
لاحياء حظوظ ترامب الرئاسيه فيما يقول
موقعه هل ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024
لن تكون مجرده تصويت على من يرغب الجمهور
بان يكون رئيسا للولايات المتحده بل
سيتحول لتصويت حول من يريد الجمهور سجنه
اهو الرئيس الحالي
ام الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حمزه
العربيه
الخطاب تذكير بالعناوت
وسلطاته دونات تواكب ان معارك عنيفه تدور
للسيطره على دار
احتجاجات مستمره في ايران رفضا للاعتقالات
العشوائيه
تونس تدخل مرحله الصوت الانتخابيه عشيه
الدوره الثانيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]